les néonazis et les membres du ku klux
klan manifeste encore en 2016 pour la
suprématie de la race blanche au
mississippi
l'état reconnu pour sa violence envers
les noirs
ces organisations font partie des 780
groupe n e recensés aux états unis
malgré leurs discours raciste leur
liberté d'expression est protégé par le
premier amendement de la constitution
américaine
il se pose à toute forme d'immigration
[Applaudissements]
est un ex-membre du kkk devenu néo nazis
ils se qualifient de séparatiste blanc
et non de raciste récemment ajoutée se
cache un point de vue sur la race
partagé par ce politicien républicain de
l'illinois qui tente de se faire élire à
la chambre des représentants à
washington partie jones est venu au
mississippi pour encourager ses
camarades néo nazis les quelques
personnes venues écouter ces groupes
racistes sont divisés
le docteur john perkins a été un chef de
file dans la dure bataille pour les
droits civiques des noirs dans les
années 1960 une bataille qu'il a mené en
prison ou mississippi où il a été battu
par des policiers appartenant au ku klux
klan il a failli mourir dans sa cellule
à force d'être frappée à la tête
barak ce score
tout le long du fleuve mississippi les
membres du ku klux klan ont tué violé
incendié des églises et comploté pour
priver les noirs de leurs droits ils
étaient 5 millions dans les années 20
ils ne sont plus que cinq mille
aujourd'hui ces cagoules qui symbolise
la haine et la violence envers les
afro-américains barennes de l'abbé quit
a été membre du ku klux klan une bonne
partie de sa vie son père leader dans le
kkk a été condamné en 1994 pour le
meurtre de m gher rêveuse un activiste
noire qui l'a tué en 1963 un assassinat
qui a soulevé les afro américains
partout aux états-unis berline de l'abbé
quid a aujourd'hui quitté le kkk un
raciste modéré qui garde ses distances
face au noir
le kkk n'a plus l'influencé qu'il avait
au mississippi les groupes néo nazis et
autres suprémacistes blancs ont pris la
relève
ils sont des dizaines de milliers aux
états unis le soir venu
nous assistons à une de leurs cérémonies
une croix gammée brûle dans une
clairière à l'abri des regards
un geste de provocation pour réaffirmer
la supériorité de la race blanche pour
les membres du mouvement
national-socialiste inspiré de l'ex
parti fasciste d'adolphe hitler
l'amérique blanche est en danger
les noirs américains ont été et sont
toujours victimes de cette idéologie
raciste
malgré tout le docteur perkins est en
croisade pour la réconciliation entre
blancs et noirs
une solution saline les bains
mais difficile de pardonner avant qu'il
y ait eu des excuses officielles pour
les temps historiques causés aux
afro-américains des excuses qu aucun
président des états unis n'a encore osé
leur offrir
[Musique]
non